welcome everybody to the Macmillan
Center we're delighted to be able to
host Shashi Tharoor as the speaker for
the 16th annual coca-cola world Fung
Fung lecture series at Yale this lecture
was established in 1992 to support
endeavours among specialists at the
intersection between international
relations international law and the
management of international enterprises
and organizations the Macmillan Center
sponsors the event along with the law
school and the School of Management
Shashi Tharoor was the official
candidate of India for the succession to
the UN secretary-general kofi annan in
2006 he has a long and distinguished
career leading up to that point he began
in 1978 when he joined the staff of the
UN High Commission of Commissioner for
Refugees in Geneva and it included key
responsibilities in peacekeeping after
the Cold War and as a senior advisor to
the Secretary General as well as the un
under-secretary-general for
communications and public information
taru is an award-winning author of nine
books and most ascended on Indian themes
perhaps his most famous book is the
great Indian novel published in 1989 his
novel showbusiness published in 1992 may
be known to many in this room because it
was made into the film Bollywood in 1994
he's also written literally hundreds of
articles op-eds and book reviews in a
wide range of publications including the
New York Times The Washington Post the
LA Times the International Herald
Tribune Time magazine Newsweek The Hindu
and The Times of India the title that
he's chosen for today's lecture I will
tell you in a minute but before doing
that I just want to
say that our session today will run
until 5:30 the lecture will be about
4550 minutes and then we will have some
time for questions and discussion
following that there will be a reception
for everybody up on the second floor and
we hope that those of you who don't get
to ask your questions during the session
will come up to the reception and
continue the conversation there but
that's enough from me the title for
today's lecture is India and China
competition cooperation or conflict
thank you and welcome thanks very much
and I could tell from that introduction
that alas you've been looking me up on
the Internet so the great danger is
these days and you come and speak to new
audiences that you suddenly start seeing
these tell tiny telltale signs and and
I'm very grateful for the kind words but
there have been occasions where
particularly at universities farmers
have been introduced by things I haven't
actually done but Ian was relatively
modest I knows I know people who look
you up on the internet and then look up
deeds and misdeeds up the family tree
those of parents and and uncles and
aunts and I'm sure one day my sons were
both yeh Lee's class of oh six will
start featuring in my introductions as
well but in one particular instance a
friend of mine was introducing a speaker
whom he looked up on the internet and he
found that this chap had been had an
uncle and uncle who'd been electrocuted
at sing-sing prison for kidnapping and
armed robbery or something equally
horrible but having taken the trouble to
look this up he felt he had to use it
they said I distinct we speak I had an
uncle who occupied the chair of applied
electricity at one of the nation's
leading institutions just by way of
saying that some of these kind words
should be taken with a pinch of salt but
thank you it's a privilege to be here at
at my as I said my my twin boys alma
mater
I'm sorry that this invitation came two
years later and parents particularly
enjoy opportunities to embarrass their
children and I feel slightly miffed that
you've deprived me of that possible I
think but nonetheless for the rest of
you I am glad to see you all here so my
topic today deals with the rise of India
and China and the world I thought I'd
turn that off but I will do so now and I
urge you all to follow my example of
course two countries two countries whose
development will have a significant
impact on the global system and on the
world sense of where international
economic and political power will shift
in the decades to come
of course India and China really two
countries out of four in that famous
acronym coined by Goldman Sachs a few
years ago BRIC for Brazil Russia India
and China whose success and prosperity
they at New York firm broadly and boldly
forecast in 2003 according to the
experts at Goldman at that time there's
a China is likely to overtake the US as
the world's largest economy by the late
2020s provided of course that it
continues its policy approaches India on
the other hand would have to do much
more in terms of economic reform and do
it more vigorously but if it did it too
could eclipse the u.s. at Goldman Sachs
by 2050 now we are of course talking in
gross terms here I think no one expects
the average Indians lifestyle to be
better than the average Americans in
2050 since there will be four times as
many Indians on the planet as Americans
but still it's it's it's rather striking
and and and well in four decades China's
per capita income even with more than a
billion people might be equal to
America's so so we're talking of some
pretty significant transformations that
Goldman was predicting because China's
per capita income today is about $2,500
to America's 40,000 and India's is just
about $800 so one would think that
America is not a valid comparator but
but according to Gordon it is now now
their analysis of course assumed that
GDP growth rates of eight to ten percent
will be sustained by both China and
India for the ten to fifteen years after
their predicts
and an India's case of course for longer
and of course we all know from recent
events that that has turned out to be an
unduly optimistic assumption we also
know that both China and India are
revising their estimated growth rates
downwards but the underlying positives
that Goldman talked about are not
entirely not entirely wrong both
countries have multiplied they're
multiplied their per capita income
levels many times over since 1950 and
they've done so far faster in recent
years than Britain or the u.s. did
during enough to the Industrial
Revolution the idea that both China and
India could triple their current
economies in the next 20 or 25 years is
not implausible to most economists and
even the World Bank and their last but
one annual assessment of global economic
prospects said as much now not an
economist and I always been profoundly
skeptical of those who issue forecasts
of any sort to music to me the future is
never quite what it used to be but few
will disagree that China and India are
going to be richer than they are now
both in absolute terms and in relative
ones and that's why it is meaningful to
speak of a of an increasing shift of
economic and as a result political power
in the world and to ask how the two
countries which force a short but brutal
war just 46 years ago we'll deal with
each other in the process now China and
India are the two most populous
countries in the world with India set to
overtake China's population around 2030
for they account for nearly a tenth of
global GDP fifth the world exports and a
sixth of all international capital flows
China and India the world's fourth well
I shouldn't really say that because
China has become third now I think it's
gone ahead of Germany so 3rd and 13th
largest economies and dollar terms they
both franc higher of course in
purchasing power parity PPP terms China
holds by far the largest foreign
currency reserves in the world at about
2 trillion half of that is held in US
paper and we all know that if it pulled
its money out of the US Treasury China
could at one stroke destroy the US
economy at some considerable cost to
itself
course which is why this won't happen
but it reflects a significant level of
us dependence on China India is not
quite in that league we can say with
some confidence that India and China
will continue to prosper and we'll pull
more millions out of poverty than
they've ever done that they will compete
effectively with Western corporations
for business that if we look at the last
few years trends it will continue to
purchase foreign companies and assets
expand their trade and overseas
investments invent and develop new
technologies and displace more economic
weight around the world and as a result
they will inevitably demand more
Authority in the international system
China already has a fair bit India will
ask for more and I do believe they will
require it China will be in my view the
country that strips the u.s. of its
current designation of being the world's
sole superpower I don't mean the China
will become the world's who'll sell
SuperPi it'll simply not bear adjectives
out of commission we'll be dealing with
a two superpower world once again and
this may happen within a generation
India will not strive the global stage
to that extent but it will be a
significant player in its own region and
through the attraction of its soft power
the strength of its culture its values
its democracy it will be hugely
influential well beyond its borders and
I think neither is going to be a bit
player a bits player on the global stage
and that's why they worth talking about
today both are currently expanding their
hard power China's military budget
increased by a staggering 17.8 percent
in 2007 I haven't seen the 2008 figures
but I gather they're close it launched
an unmanned space orbiter last year and
announced a major expansion of its naval
and submarine fleet India's behind but
it's broadly heading in the same
direction many of you know that India
recently became one of a handful of
countries I think for countries to land
a lunar probe on the moon
India's also committed more and more to
to expanding its its military budget
developing serious Bluewater Navy and
there was involved in a naval engagement
off the African coast
a few months ago against a a pirate ship
so we're talking about countries whose
rich is going significantly beyond their
immediate borders or at least their
potential reaches still of course both
countries together would have a long way
to go before they can compete with the
US because defense budget is currently
equal to that of the rest of the world
combined so it would be foolish to
suggest that military power is also
shifting to the east in absolute terms
but I I still think that that what's
happening is is again significant in
terms of its effect on the overall
balance globally I'm not one of those
who shares in the formulation of the
British historian Neil Ferguson who in
the last chapter of his recent book the
war of the world wrote of the dissent of
the West I don't think the rise of the
East needs to imply the fall of the West
and certainly I think what we're talking
about is at best a rebalancing not some
sort of shift of power from the Western
world to China and India but even this
of course would only be a partial
reversion to the historical state of
affairs according to the economic
historian Angus Madison back in 1820
China and India together accounted for
nearly half of the world's total
economic output in their fifth of global
GDP China nearly 27 percent in 1820
neither is close to those numbers today
even the most optimistic projections for
their rise do not see these two
countries in the imaginable future
accounting for 50 percent of global GDP
any time in the 21st century so even if
we're talking about some genuine
remarkably interesting numbers in terms
of the shift of economic capacity it
would not bring these two countries back
to the position they occupied
individually or together just two
centuries ago but to look at the recent
rise of these two countries is however
remarkably instructive those who visited
China during Mao's time would not
recognize it today it's a country that
has remade itself physically to a point
that
it's visible physical infrastructure is
almost entirely new the extraordinary
cities with their dense forest of
skyscrapers their six lane expressways
studded with overpasses their gleaming
modern airports their large and
throbbing ports at one point they I'm
sure that by now tired joke but the
national bird of China ought to be the
crane since there's so many of them
around the country the transformation
has been so dramatic that a little
fishing village in 1990 calls Shenzhen
is now one of the world's largest and
most prosperous modern cities the rows
of masked bicycles across Beijing have
given way to choking fleets of spanking
new cars the dull Graham our tunics have
old have been replaced by colorful
clothes of the latest styles and cut
made or at least copied in China itself
the supermarket's overflowed with
consumer goods of every conceivable
description again mainly made in China
and exported to the rest of the world
including to those countries that design
those products in the first place
institutions are acquiring new habits
and traditions undreamt of in the Maoist
bla past a few years ago I was invited
to speak at Beijing University and for
my pains I was presented when they
handsome red and whites official
University tie so when I returned to UN
headquarters in New York I made it a
point to wear my new tie at a meeting
with a senior Chinese official who I
knew had graduated from Peking
University he made no comment about the
tie so I was provoked to ask him don't
you recognize what I'm wearing no he
replied and then it struck me when he
had attended Peking University they had
been no such thing as an official
University tie for the simple reason
that in those days no one in China even
wore a tie so China has little use for
ancient or even recent tradition it
simply invents a new tradition when it
has need of one instead of being hemmed
in behind tightly controlled borders
Chinese are now free to travel and study
abroad
I'm sure quite a few here at Yale almost
a million have done so in the last three
decades including some 130,000 currently
studying in foreign countries acquiring
skills at many a majority maybe most
were bring back to their native land the
private sector unknown in Mao's
it's fair to rival the state-owned
enterprises that were the initial
engines of China's growth and prosperity
it's not all good news
China has also more polluted than ever
before with air unfit to breathe
visibility in Beijing shockingly limited
by smog and rivers poisoned by toxic
effluence it's also a much more unequal
Society and irony for a country that
still calls itself a People's Republic
and is ruled by an ostensibly communist
party what about India I could say a
great deal more about my own country but
perhaps I'll permit myself just one
illustrative example since my most
recent book the elephant the tiger and
the cellphone is about the recent
transformation of India two thirds of
the title uh perhaps is perhaps
self-explanatory it's in days the land
of the animal fable there's perhaps many
of you know I begin with a bunch of some
prototype fable about India thinly
disguised as the adverb isn't accurate
as an elephant a sort of lumbering
slumbering ponderous beast marred and
its own dust and mud covered in flies
slow move slow to change that somehow in
recent years appears to be acquiring the
stripes of a sinewy life and agile tiger
well whereas a cellphone coming you
might ask well to me the cell phone is
the instrument that most epitomizes this
change see I grew up in an India in
which telephones were pretty rare in
fact when I left India in 1975 to go to
the US for Graduate Studies we had
perhaps 600 million residents in the
country and there were just two million
landline telephones having a telephone
was a rare privilege if you weren't a
wealthy businessman or an important
government official or a doctor or a
journalist you might just languish in a
long waiting list for phones and never
get one
in fact so rare with telephones and
members of parliament elected members of
parliament had amongst their privileges
the right to allocate 15 telephone
connections to anybody the 15 people
they deemed worthy if you did have a
phone it wasn't necessarily a blessing
I spent my high school years in Calcutta
and I remember the phone sitting in the
front hall and each day would pick it up
and hopefully you know pray for a dial
tone which usually was not in fact
available if you got a dial tone and you
dialed a number the words you heard more
often than hello were wrong number
or you might actually be connected to a
call except it wasn't the call you dial
it's an ongoing conversation amongst two
people who are blissfully unaware that
you've just joined their conversation
there was even a technical term for this
it was called a cross connection these
are connections that made us very cross
and then if you wanted to call another
city let's say from Calcutta where
professor Chandra there and I spent some
time you said to call Delhi you have to
book something called a trunk call and
then you sat by the phone all day
waiting for the call to come through or
you could pay eight times the going rate
was a very high going rate for something
called a lightning call but in those
days even lightning struck rather slowly
in India because the lightning call
Tuukka minimum of half an hour to come
through whereas a trunk call took
several hours frankly as late as 1980
for when a member of parliament rose to
protest this woeful appalling service by
what was a a public sector monopoly a
government service are then
communications minister replied in a
lordly manner that communications in a
developing country are a luxury not a
right that the government had no
obligation to provide better service and
if the Honorable member was not
satisfied with his telephone could he
please return it since there was an 8
year long waiting list of people waiting
for this inadequate instrument now
fast-forward to today but I finished
writing my book which was in May of 2007
I was able to report in it that in April
2007 India had just set a new world
record by selling seven million
cellphones that month which was actually
more telephone connections that had been
established by any country the US and
China included in any one month in the
history of telecommunications well the
book you know went off to the publishers
and got printed and bound and arrived in
all good bookstores even New Haven and
that figure was already out of date
because by the time it hit the
bookstores in December of 2007 India had
broken into
record three times and at so late point
three million cell phones that month the
book I'm pleased to say is still in
print but the figure is even more
woefully out of date
last July India sold nine point two two
million cell phones in October breached
the 10 million barrier January of this
year 11 million cell phones and last
month though the figures are still
unofficial it may have actually sold 15
million so the so India has now
overtaken the US as the world's second
largest telephone market did that
already in January it's smaller than
China but growing a lot faster and what
you're seeing is not just a story of
numbers not even just a story of
attitudes from the that of the
Communications Minister I quoted to me
enlightened telecoms Regulatory
Authority of today but it's also very
interesting question of who's carrying
these cellphones most of you non-indians
here when you go to India which I hope
you all do will be driven everywhere not
just if you happen to be in a position
where you get a chauffeur-driven car but
even if you just go and rent a car
because India is one of those countries
where the car rental companies know it's
actually cheaper by the way for you to
rent a car with a driver than without
one because the car rental companies
know that if you haven't grown up
driving in India their risk go up with
the rent your car without a driver so
you'll have a driver okay
99% chance your drivers carrying a
cellphone and it won't be one that the
company's given him he can afford it
because we have the cheapest cell phone
rates in the world
they average indian cell phone bill is
four dollars a month if you was a delhi
go to the suburbs of delhi on the side
streets of the suburbs of Delhi you'll
find a fellow with a wooden cart that
looks like it was invented in the 18th
century on a dress a coal-fired steam
iron that looks like it was invented in
the 19th century it's got an Easter
Ivana his job was to take an ironing
from the neighborhood and he'll be
carrying that 21st century instruments
her cell phone because in most indian
plans incoming calls are all free so it
costs him nothing to get a call from an
apartment saying come and pick up a sari
or a shirt to iron a few months ago I
visited the country farm of a friend of
mine in the southern state of Kerala the
rural area about 20 kilometers
away from any place you'd consider urban
dotted with coconut trees I was a hot
day they said hey would you like some
fresh coconut water which of course is
the best thing to drink most refreshing
most nutritious thing in a tropical
country on our day so I said sure so he
whipped out a cell phone dialed a number
and a voice said I'm up here and right
on top of the nearest coconut tree with
his waist cloth tied around his knees I
hat it in one hand and a cell phone and
the other was the local toddy tapper who
promptly brought down a couple of
coconuts for us to drink fishermen in
Kerala now going out to sea with their
cell phones and after they catch their
fish they're calling every market town
along the coast to find out what it
costs which market will offer them the
best price for the fish they of course
so fish prices are going up with the
fishermen are earning better livelihoods
farmers in the old days at harvest time
a farmer would either have to trudge off
the market town or send an able-bodied
relative it might be an 80 year old boy
on a 1012 kilometre walk to the nearest
market town go and see if the market was
open go and see whether the particular
product they just harvested could be
sold what price they would fetch then
the poor kid would walk back the 10 or
10 kilometers give the news to the
farmer they would then load the carts
head off to the market town half a day's
Brak back-breaking labor now save with
1/2 minute phone call in other words the
cell phone as a symbol of India's
transformation simply because it has
empowered the Indian underclass in ways
in which 45 years of talk about
socialism like China's 45 years of talk
about communism had singularly failed to
do but of course there's still a long
way to go it's it's become a cliche to
speak of India as a land of paradoxes
the old joke about our country is that
anything you say about India the
opposite is also true
we like to think of ourselves as an
ancient civilization but we're also a
young Republic our information
technology experts tried confidently
into the into the 21st century but much
of our population seems to live in each
of the other 20 centuries quite often
the opposites exist coexist quite
cheerfully one of my favorite images of
India that actually went around the
internet so some of you may have seen it
is a photograph from the last kumbhamela
the big Hindu religious festival of a
naked South
straight out of central casting it came
matted hair scraggly beard gap teeth
grin beads around his neck naked torso
and in this photograph this naked holy
man was chatting away on a cell phone
and and this this I even suggested it to
the publishers of my of my new book as a
perfect cover image but they assured me
it was so well known it had become a
cliche in itself and so they put another
cliche on the cover but that's what
publishers do but cliches are cliches
because they're true and the paradox of
India the paradoxes of India say
something painfully real about our
society a place where bullock-carts are
still an indispensable mode of
transportation for millions but as
rocket and satellite programs are
amongst the most advanced on earth so
having given you this very sketchy brief
portrait of the of the of the rise of
China in India I'd like to reflect on
two aspects of a rise first the question
of commonalities competition
complementarities between the two of
them and second the risk of conflict
there are many other aspects obviously
of the rise of China and India and which
I wish I could dilate and I dare say
there are people in this room who know
more about much of this than I do but in
the limited time available that's what
I'll focus on I look forward to a lively
exchange in the discussion that will
follow
so first commonalities complementarities
competition it's become rather
fashionable these days and in being upon
small circles in the West to speak of
India and China in the same breath bees
were too recently the two big countries
said to be taking over the world the new
contenders for global eminence after
centuries of Western domination the
orient Lancer two generations of
Occidental economic success last year
two new books came out explicitly or was
2007 perhaps well late 2007 earlier it
explicitly twinning the two countries
there was Forbes magazine correspondent
Robin Meredith's the elephant and the
dragon the rise of India and China and
what it means for all of us and there
was Harvard Business professor Theron
Connors billions of entrepreneurs how
China and India are reshaping their
futures and yours both books though
different in scope and tone
see the rise of India and China is
literally shifting the world's economic
and political tectonic plates some even
speak of Chindia as if the two are
joined at the hip in the international
imagination the personal account me
amongst the skeptics it's not just that
aside from the fact that both countries
occupy a rather vast landmass called
Asian
they have very little in common it's
also that the two countries are already
at very different stages of development
China started its liberalisation in 1978
a good decade and a half before India it
shot up faster it had double-digit
growth when India was still hovering
around 5% and with compound growth it's
put itself in a totally different league
from India continuing to grow faster
from a larger base but it's also that
the two country systems are totally
dissimilar if China wants to build a new
six lane expressway as they decided they
wanted to from 1990 onwards China can
bulldoze its way past any number of
villages in its path and it's done so in
India if you want to widen a two-lane
road you could be tied up in court for a
dozen years over compensation
entitlements when China built the Three
Gorges Dam it created a 660 kilometer
long reservoir that necessitated the
displacement of a staggering two million
people and it managed to accomplish all
that in 15 years without a fuss in the
interests of generating electricity when
India began the nut mother dam project
aiming to bring irrigation drinking
water and power to hundreds of millions
of people
it has since spent 34 years so far
fighting environmental groups human
rights activists and advocates for the
displaced all the way to the Supreme
Court while still being thwarted in the
streets by protesters from
non-governmental organizations like they
save nor mother movement now this is how
it should be
India is a fractious democracy China is
not but as an Indian I do not wish to
pretend that we can compete in the
global growth stakes with China in fact
in case anyone wanted confirmation that
Chindia twinning India with China is to
put it mildly premature one is only to
look at the medals tally at the last
Beijing Olympics China proudly ranked
first with 51 gold medals
a total of 100 medals altogether you
have to strain your eyes past such deaf
children of the global families Jamaica
Belarus war-torn Georgia collapsing
Zimbabwe and even what used to be called
Outer Mongolia before stumbling across
India in 50th place with precisely three
medals one gold and two bronze now this
is not in fact a surprise whereas China
said about systematically striving for
Olympic success since ad reinterred
global competition after years of
isolation India has remained complacent
about its lack of sporting prowess where
China lobbied for and won the right to
host the Olympics within two decades of
its return to the games India rested on
its laurels after hosting the Asian
Games in Delhi in 1982 so that it is now
considered further behind in the
competition for Olympic hosts good then
it was two decades ago where China
embarked on project not one not one one
nine which is a program devised
specifically to boost the country's
Olympic medal standings the number one
one nine refers to the number of goals
awarded at the Sydney games of 2000 in
such medal Laden sports as track and
field swimming rowing sailing and
canoeing we Indians wondered we would be
able to crack the magic ceiling of to
the highest number of medals our country
had ever won of this quadrennial
exercise in international sporting
barkis mo where China seeing the number
of medals awarded in kayaking decided to
create a team to master a sport hitherto
unknown in the Middle Kingdom India did
not even lobby successfully for the
inclusion on the Olympic Games of the
few sports we do play well cupboard II
for instance a form of tag-team
wrestling or polo or even cricket which
was played in the Olympics of 1900 and
has been omitted since where China has
maintained its dominance in table tennis
and badminton and developed new
strengths in non-traditional sports like
rowing and shooting India has seen its
months legendary invincibility in field
hockey fade with the introduction of
astroturf to the point where our team
even failed to qualify for Beijing this
year so forget CH India two countries
barely belong in the same sporting
sentence
but what's happened in the Olympics
speaks to a basic difference in the two
country systems it's the creative chaos
of all-singing all-dancing bollywood
versus the perfectly choreographed
precision of the Beijing Games opening
ceremony the Chinese as befits an
autocracy approach the task of
dominating the Olympics with top-down
military discipline the objective was
determined a program project
one-one-nine was drawn up the
considerable resources of the state were
attached to it
state-of-the-art technology acquired
world-class foreign coaches imported
India by contrast approached these
Olympics as it had every other with its
usual combination of amiable amateurism
bureaucratic ineptitude half-hearted
experiment and shambolic organization in
China national priorities are
established by the government and then
funded by the state in China priorities
emerge a bigger part in India priorities
emerge from seemingly endless
discussions and arguments amongst myriad
interests and funds have to be found
where they might China's budget for
preparing its sports persons for these
games alone exceeded all of India's
expenditure on all Olympic training for
the previous 60 years many of India's
national endeavors remind me of the old
saw that I heard three decades ago when
I first told the corridors of the
Ministry of External Affairs in India I
was told then by a grizzled old veteran
of Indian diplomacy that Indian
diplomacy is like the lovemaking of an
elephant
he said it's conducted at a very high
level accompanied by much bellowing and
the results are not known for two years
now this is no longer true I'm happy to
say of Indian diplomacy but it is the
last true of many Indian economic
reforms and other schemes like Olympic
participation so I'll promulgated from
on high with much fanfare and then take
an age to be implemented because of all
the interest to be accommodated all the
vested interests and obstacles that have
to be overcome but where China's
state-owned enterprises remain the most
powerful motors of the country's
development India's private sector
ducking around governmental obstacles
and bypassing the stifling patronage of
the state has actually transformed the
fortunes of the Indian people that's the
cell phone story
for you sowed proved again in the
Olympics the wrestlers boxers runners
tennis players and weight lifters are
made up the bulk of the Indian
contingent accompanied by the inevitable
retinue of officials returned with just
two bronzes amongst them while India's
only gold in shooting was won by a young
entrepreneur with a rifle range in his
own backyard and no help from the state
whatsoever young avi Ravindra is at 25
the CEO of a high-tech firm a
self-motivated sharpshooter who financed
his own equipment and training and an
avid blogger he is in short a 21st
century Indian at one level it's not
surprising that he should have won
India's first individual gold in any
Olympics in fact ever since a
transplanted Englishman competed in
Indian colors in the 1900 games India is
the land of individual excellence
despite the limitations of the system in
China individual success is the product
of the system but if we can compete can
we cooperate the two civilizations had
centuries of contact in ancient times
thanks mainly to the export of Buddhism
from India to China Chinese travelers
came to Indian universities going back
1,600 years visited Indian courts wrote
memorable accounts of their voyages none
on the university which flourished in
northern India for seven centuries from
427 ad and attracted students from
across Asia received hundreds of Chinese
students in its time and a few Indians
went the other way a buddhist monk from
india built the famous Ling forgive my
the Chinese ever forgive my
pronunciation leniency temple in Wong
Joe in the 5th century in South West
India careless coastline is dotted with
chinese fishing nets and the favorite
cooking pot of the Malayala housewife is
the wok which is locally called the chin
jetty which means Chinese vessel it's
been a while though since Indians and
Chinese had much to do with each other
the heady days of Hindi tini by by
Indians and Chinese are brothers
the slogan coined by Nehru vien India to
welcome Joe and ly in 1955 gave way to
the humiliation
the 1962 border war after which it was
Hindi tini bye-bye for decades the
bitter border dispute between the two
countries remains unresolved
but periodic reports of incursions by
Chinese troops onto Indian soil and new
irritants over anti-chinese protests of
Tibetan exiles have been given asylum in
India and I'll come back to this later
when we talk about potential conflict to
speak of a trust deficit between the two
countries is arguably an understatement
and yet there has been some good news
trade doubled for three years in a row
to an estimated forty billion dollars
this year 2008 China has now overtaken
the US last year as the as India's
largest single trading partner the two
countries have publicly said they will
raise their bilateral trade flow to
sixty billion dollars by 2010 and they
aiming for 100 billion dollars by 2014
both New Delhi and Beijing are
emphasizing that they want to be quote
cooperative partners not competitors to
quote the words of Chinese Premier Wen
Jiabao during his visit to India in
November 2006 China's president who
Jintao agreed on a 10-point plan with
Prime Minister Manmohan Singh to
increase cooperation with a focus
specifically on commercial and economic
exchanges who spoke of what what he
described as the enormous potential for
increased bilateral business ties when
Prime Minister Manmohan Singh visited
China in January of 2008 he and Premier
Wen agreed to increase the volume of our
lateral trade and also to resolve their
border issues through peaceful
negotiation that's not all tourism
particularly of Indian pilgrims to the
major Hindu holy sites and Tibet Mount
Kailash and Lake man Sarovar is thriving
Indian information technology firms have
opened offices in Shanghai and Hangzhou
Infosys the big Indian computer firm in
Bangalore recruited nine Chinese last
year for their headquarters there are
dozens of Chinese engineers working in
and learning from Indian computer firms
and engineering companies while Indian
software engineers in Chennai and
Bangalore are supporting the Chinese
telecoms equipment manufacturer while
by-and-large India is good of things
that China needs to improve that notably
software China excels at hardware and
manufacturing which India sorely lacks
so india's Mahindra and Mahindra
manufactures tractors in nan Chang for
export to the United States the key
operating components of apples iPod were
invented in India by the Hyderabad
company portal player but the iPods
themselves are manufactured in China
Philips employs nearly 3000 Indians at
its innovation campus in Bangalore who
write more than 20% to Philips global
software which in turn goes to Philips
50,000 strong workforce in China to turn
into brand-name goods in other words the
elephant is already dancing with the
dragon the only question is whether the
two countries can prolong the dance or
whether political tensions could bring
the music screeching to a halt there is
no doubt that whatever the differences
between the two countries cooperation is
in the best interests of both India and
China the two countries have economic
complementarities that could make such
cooperation mutually beneficial as the
examples have given you of companies in
both countries already proving but of
course the issue gets fairly complicated
particularly if one sees the question of
comparative advantages and assumes that
China is way ahead of India in every
respect if the stories is a little more
nuanced in absolute numbers the Chinese
are way ahead China's export of
electronic goods now tops 180 billion a
year one out of every three shoes of
maybe I should say pairs of shoes
exported in the world is made in China
they make seventy five percent of the
world's toys and foreign direct
investment of course isn't at the level
of seventy billion dollars a year for
comparison India was proud to end last
year at a record level of 25 billion
Shanghai alone has nearly 4,000
skyscrapers which is not only more than
all of India but exceeds those of Los
Angeles and Chicago combined China has
built an estimated 60,000 kilometers of
expressways and less than two decades
and will soon outstrip the entire
for the US highway network per-capita
income has risen nearly tenfold since
1978 and the number of people living in
absolute poverty in China has dropped
from a figure of 425 million two decades
ago to an official figure of 26 million
today the population is almost totally
literate life expectancy is reaching
developed country levels and as I
briefly mentioned earlier China has
overtaken Germany to become the world's
third largest economy
behind the u.s. and Japan but it won't
stay number three for long but against
this are a number of factors that
suggest that not everything is rosy
economic growth has occurred at
breakneck speed but that means some
necks have been broken the human cost of
development in China has not been
negligible population displacement
farmers thrown off their lands villages
flooded by dams mounting pollution low
wage labour and appalling conditions
widening disparities between the rich
and the poor an absence of human rights
and few checks on governmental abuses
the Chinese have seen great and rapid
improvements in the internet access but
Beijing still employs some 40,000 cyber
police to monitor politically
undesirable activity on the web equally
important China's success has not just
been China's a disproportionate share of
the benefits goes abroad to the foreign
companies that have set up factories in
China it's been estimated that of the
$700 American price of a Chinese made
laptop only $15 actually remains in
China only four of the country's top 25
exporters are Chinese companies
according to Robin Meredith who adds in
practice who adds that in practice quote
made in China really means made by
America or Europe in China
unquote the Chinese financial system
also has a way to go whereas India has
been running sophisticated stock markets
since the early 19th century and my
competitors are so skilled at doing so
that they got the Bombay Stock Exchange
up and running within 24 hours of a
terrorist bomb blast that nearly
destroyed the building in 1992 China is
new of the game and not particularly
adept at it the financial information
provided by China's companies especially
those in the larger
mental sector is notoriously unreliable
and standards of corporate governance
are low there are no world-class Chinese
companies but sophisticated managers to
match Tata or Wipro or Infosys China's
capital markets are weak in its banks
inefficient the Chinese banking system
carried an estimated nine hundred and
eleven billion dollars in unrecoverable
loans as of 2007 mainly to government
firms in his recent book capitalism with
Chinese characteristics professor yang
Wang of MIT argues that the Indian
private sector is more efficient and
entrepreneurial than the Chinese private
sector state-owned enterprises still
account for half of China's economic
assets China has yet to master the art
of channeling domestic savings into
productive investments which is why it
has relied so extensively on foreign
direct investment India on the other
hand does without it's actually exported
FDI to OECD countries Indian capitalists
of bought assets in the developed world
in other words India's entrepreneurial
capital and management skills are better
able than China's to control and manage
assets in the sophisticated financial
markets of the developed West and the
world is yet to develop any confidence
in China's legal system where a contract
still means whatever the government says
it means in other words it still lags
behind India on the software of
development not just technical
brainpower or engineering know-how but
the system's it needs to operate a 21st
century economy in an open and
globalizing world the Chinese state is
undoubtedly stronger and more efficient
than the Indian state but the Indian
private sector is not only miles ahead
of the Chinese private sector it's
compensating for the inadequacies of the
state whereas in China the state sector
can still stifle the private and both
sides know it and then there's politics
whatever we might say about India's
sclerotic bureaucracy versus China's
efficient one
India's tangles of red tape versus
China's red carpet its unfurled red
carpet to foreign investors India's
contentious and fractious political
parties versus China's smooth
functioning top-down communist hierarchy
there's still one thing you've got to
grant India has become an outstanding
example of the management of diversity
through pluralist democracy every Indian
has been allowed to feel that he or she
has as much of a stake in the country
and as much of a chance to run it as
anyone else
after all our last elections five years
ago were won by an Italian woman of
Roman Catholic faith and Italian
background as I said who then made way
for a Sikh to be sworn in this Prime
Minister by a Muslim president in a
country 81 percent Hindu and our largest
state today is ruled by a Dalit woman a
woman of the so-called untouchable
outcast community and somebody who by
the way bids fair to have a crack at
ruling the entire country if she can
make the coalition arithmetic add up
right after the next election and she
wasn't promoted by the Brahmin elite in
New Delhi she rode to the top on the
ballots of her political base building
her own rainbow coalition along the way
contrast this with Beijing where
political freedom is unknown leaders at
all levels are hand-picked from the top
from their PO for their posts and
political heresy is met with stiff Swift
punishment house arrest or worse during
the Olympics on the international
pressure China designated a few areas
where protesters could in ferry
peacefully gather but you had to apply
for permission to protest which was
never granted and most of those who
applied were arrested and detained which
meant that the authorization the protest
became an excellent method for the
security police to identify potential
troublemakers without having to actually
take the trouble of looking for them
India's politics means that it's shock
absorbers are built into the system it
has endured major road bumps
secessionist movements terrorist
violence you name it without the vehicle
ever breaking down in China's case the
limousine of State is driving smoothly
along those expressways but it's far
from clear what would happen if that
limousine of state actually ever
encountered a serious pothole the
present system wasn't designed to cope
with fundamental challenges to it except
through repression but every autocratic
stage in history has come to a point
repression was no longer enough if that
point is reached in China all bets are
off the dragon the dragon could stumble
where the elephant can always trample
all but as an Indian I'm not trying to
be complacent India's problems are
enormous and there's still a great deal
we need to do internally our teeming
cities overflow while two out of three
Indians still scratch a living from the
soil we've been recognized for practical
purposes now as a nuclear power but 600
million Indians still have no access to
electricity and there are daily power
cuts brownouts even in the nation's
capital ours as a culture which elevated
non-violence to an effective moral
principle but our freedom was born in
blood and I independent still soaks in
it we are the world's leading
manufacturers of generic medication for
illnesses such as AIDS but we have three
million of our own citizens suffering
from HIV who don't have access to AIDS
medication another two million with TB
and tens of millions with no health
center or clinic within a 10-kilometer
walk of their places of residence I
talked about India holding the world
record for the number of cell phones
sold but we also hold the world record
for the number of farmers suicides
17,000 Indian farmers kill themselves
last year because when the harvests
failed
they're under crippling mountain of
deaths the only way they see out for
themselves is to take their own lives
even though India has more dollar
billionaires than any country in Asia
certainly more than China even more than
Japan which has been richer for longer
we also have 260 million people living
below the poverty line and this is not
the UN or World Bank poverty line has
recently been revised to $1 25 a day
it's the Indian poverty line calculated
in rupees in rural India at three
hundred and sixty rupees a month under
30 cents a day so it's a poverty line
drawn just this side of the funeral pyre
and there are people above that poverty
line who would be considered poorer by
UN or World Bank standards we've trained
world-class scientists and engineers
many of whom were started companies in
Silicon Valley but 400 million of our
compatriots are illiterate and we have
more children who've never seen the
inside of a school than any other
country in the world has India has a
great demographic advantage in
540 million young people under 25 today
which means we should have a dynamic
youthful and productive workforce for
the next 40 years when the rest of the
world including China is aging but we
also have 60 million child labourers and
72% of the children in our government
schools drop out by the eighth grade we
celebrate India's IT triumphs but
information technology has employed a
grand total of five million people while
10 million are entering the workforce
each year and we don't have jobs for
them many of our urban youth rightly say
with confidence that their future will
be better than their parents past but
whereas Maoism is confined to ideologues
textbooks in China in fact a Hong Kong
businessman friend of mine a Chinese
friend said to me the only place you
truly meet a Maoist is in India there
are Maoist insurgency is violently
disturbing the peace in 165 of India 602
districts and these are largely made up
of unemployed young men in other words
India has a great deal still to do to
ensure that it keeps its people healthy
well-fed and secure secure not just from
Islamist terrorism which has been in the
headlines and it's a real threat but
also from the daily terror of poverty
hunger and ill health the progress is
being made India has had success in
carrying out three kinds of revolutions
and feeding its people a green
revolution you've all heard about in
food grains and white revolution and
milk production and at least some degree
of blue revolution and the development
of fisheries but the benefits of these
revolutions have not had reached the
quarter of our population living below
that poverty line and we have to do that
before we can meaningfully speak of
competing with China I'd be a little
briefer on the subject of the risk of
conflict between the two countries so we
can have 20 odd minutes for our exchange
as Indians painfully remember we went to
war in 1962 a decisive crime for China
which rested 23200 square kilometers of
Indian territory at the same time
Beijing has taken pains in recent years
to remind India that it still claims a
further 90 2,000 square kilometers
mainly in the northeastern
in state about a natural Pradesh it
doesn't help that the two countries
share the longest disputed frontier in
the world since the line of actual
control of the LA Sea has never been
formally delineated in a manner accepted
by both sides India's borders were
defined by British imperial
administrators in the 1913 McMahon Line
which China rejects visibly India that
accepts that line as its frontier with
Burma Myanmar which it was in those days
part of British India with ELAC coming
into being in the wake of 62 the
situation is even more unclear whenever
troops from either side build roads
construct or repair their bunkers and
other routine fortifications or conduct
patrols close to the LA sea tensions can
and do repeatedly flare up when the two
sides are anxious to avoid provoking
each other such activities are kept to a
minimum but it would seem that Beijing
has taken a conscious decision in the
last couple of years to keep India on
its toes why do I say that well the
first six months of last year before the
Olympic lull witnessed a proliferation
of incidents along the 4,000 457
kilometer frontier between the two
countries it's continued after the
Olympics an unofficial figure I saw in
December put the number 213 incursions
with a month to go last year up from 172
the previous year
these included no further than 65
incursions by the People's Liberation
Army in just one sector alone the
evocatively named finger area in Sikkim
which has a 200 kilometer border but
Tibet reports of intrusions into Indian
Territory have continued they seem to be
getting more brazen in one reported
incident Chinese soldiers entered 15
kilometers into Indian Territory in
Ladakh and actually burned the Indian
patrolling base while Indian spokesmen
appear anxious to downplay such reports
in an earlier incident inside the LA sea
a mixed civilian military team
investigating reports of a previous
Chinese incursion on the frontier were
threatened and forced to retreat by a
PLA formation and three armored vehicles
the Chinese soldiers allegedly assumed
firing positions in the incident leading
the Indians to withdraw in order not to
provoke a shooting match
and there are many many more such
examples that I'm going to skip more
patrolling and so on China establishing
four new air bases in Tibet three and
other southern provinces bordering India
the Indian Air Force then augmenting its
own presence near the Chinese border one
could well ask what on earth is going on
but fears of imminent major hostilities
more in other words are clearly
overblown China flush from the huge
public relations success of the Olympics
is hardly likely to initiate a clash and
India has no desire whatsoever to
provoke its northern neighbor offsetting
the stories of border incursions are
good news stories like the joint
military exercises in December can you
imagine the Chinese army in Indian Army
which had gone to war 46 years earlier
had joined military exercises last
December at which the Chinese soldiers
euphonious Li sang the Indian national
anthem in an impeccable accent and the
reported it didn't stop at janaganamana
the national anthem a few Chinese
soldiers showed their mastery of
Bollywood music by breaking out into a
Hindi hit film song to the appreciation
of Indian soldiers now this is all to
the good but there's still a fundamental
problem it's clear that China's troubles
over Tibet the beginning of last year
have brought with them unwelcome
reminders to Beijing of India's
hospitality to the Dalai Lama and his
government in exile ironically during
the mass protests in Tibet in early 2008
the one country that was conspicuous
both by its centrality to the drama and
by its reticence over it was India on
the question of Tibet both as the land
of asylum for the Dalai Lama and of
course of the angry young hotheads of
the Tibetan Youth Congress India finds
itself on the horns of dilemma of a
dilemma on the one hand we are a
democracy when there is a long tradition
of allowing peaceful protests including
against foreign countries when their
leaders come visiting us we provided
refuge to the Dalai Lama when he fled
the Chinese occupation of his homeland
in 1959 we've granted asylum and
eventually Indian citizenship to over
110,000 Tibetan refugees and though
we've permitted them to set up a
government in exile we have not
recognized in New Delhi does not
recognize the government in exile as a
government but it allows them to live
and function in
picturesque Himalayan Hilton Dharamsala
on the other hand we've been assiduously
cultivating better relations with China
though the bitter border dispute as I've
described it remains unresolved and
China has been a vital ally and military
supplier to India's enemies across the
border and Pakistan the coup two
countries have been warming to each
other in recent years so Delhi is always
try to draw a distinction between its
humanitarian obligations as a country of
asylum and its political
responsibilities as a friend of China so
the Dalai Lama and follows a tool we
respect you as a religious leader and
what you're trying to do religiously but
you can't conduct political activities
when the young Tibetan radicals wanted
to March to Lhasa the Indian police
stopped them well before they got to the
border and detained the protesters when
some Tibetan demonstrators outside the
Chinese embassy in New Delhi attacked
the premises the Indian government
stepped up its level of protection for
the Chinese diplomats and and the Indian
Foreign Minister used the occasion of a
press conference alongside the American
Secretary of State County Rice last year
to publicly warn the Dalai Lama against
doing anything that could have a
negative impact on sino-indian relations
so Indian officials have shown their
cute consciousness of how sensitive the
Chinese are on the question of the Dalai
Lama having said that and despite some
political controversy in the country
about it
India has has really tried to make an
effort not to alienate its largest
trading partner and it's sort of dancing
delicately on the Tibetan tightrope and
yet the dangers are real because the
fact is that the Wong the birthplace of
the sixth
Dalai Lama a couple hundred years ago
and a major monastery of Tibetan
Buddhism lies in Arunachal Pradesh and
this deprives Beijing of a vital asset
in its attempts to assert total control
over Tibet there's no doubt that Beijing
is hoping once the Dalai Lama passes on
that they will find a suitable young boy
in Tibet whisk him off to Beijing
educate an indoctrination for some time
and and then have a Dalai Lama who tows
the Beijing line I mean that clearly is
their intention but the Dalila
the present one has announced that the
next there are may not be born in
Chinese controlled Tibetan lands the
suggestion is that he could easily
emerge from the Tibetan diaspora or from
traditional areas of Tibetan residents
that are now in India notably that the
long tract the very fact that one day
lama has emerged from the wrong makes
that a potential area produce another
one could be acceptable to the Tibetan
people reminding New Delhi of China's
claims to this territories therefore all
the more urgent for Beijing China would
like to take control of the one before
it's too late
and that's why these tensions have been
accelerating in my view and examples of
surprisingly undiplomatic treatment of
visiting Indian Foreign Minister last
summer and so on and I think behind the
unpleasantness lies a broader strategic
calculation at the end of the Cold War
Beijing had two options in relation to
India to see the country as a natural
ally together with Russia in building up
an alternative Pole to u.s. dominance in
the region this by the way has many
starry-eyed Indian intellectuals behind
such an approach or to identify India as
a potential adversary to its own
aspirations the emergence of a stronger
US Indian partnership in recent years
appears to have convinced China to place
new delhi in the latter category even
seeing it as a possible instrument of
containment of china now such a
perception may have been reinforced by
India's frequent military exercises with
the u.s. u.s. Japan and Australia in
this cultivation of the former Soviet
stands in Central Asia including the
establishment of an Indian military base
in Tajikistan and India's attempts in
recent years to establish very thick
ties with countries that Beijing perhaps
sees as falling within its own sphere of
influence from Mongolia to Vietnam
and including direct competition over
Myanmar indeed India's refusal to
condemn the Burmese hunters crackdown on
monks in mid 2007 was directly linked to
India's competition with China for
influence strategic assets and oil and
gas from that unhappy country because
our earlier policy of support for
Burma's democratic forces had simply
allowed China and its ally Pakistan to
steal a march on
India's Look East Policy developing
closer relations where the countries of
Southeast Asia is not necessarily China
directed but it would be disingenuous to
deny that one of the reasons many
Southeast Asian countries welcome
India's involvement in their
neighborhood is to offset China's
overweening predominance in the region a
quick checklist of other factors that
have added to the strains in the
relationship one is the Indo u.s.
nuclear deal China has been concerned
about the American willingness to create
an Indian exception which they fear is
an attempt to build up India as a
strategic counterweight to China and
China Mary's hesitations apparent in the
Nuclear Suppliers group thus incurring
if not our Roth certainly public
statements of disapproval and
disappointment from senior officials in
New Delhi second is China's support for
Pakistan including military systems and
help for Pakistan's nuclear program as
well as support via North Korea for
Pakistan's missile program which
confirms Indian suspicions that China
wishes to use our troublesome neighbor
to keep our regional ambitions let alone
global in check China's development to
the port of Gwadar and Pakistan and of a
Burmese port on the Bay of Bengal
reflecting its development of a naval
capacity on India's flanks has our
strategists increasingly worried on
Beijing side India's inclusion in the
East Asian summit which was pushed by
Japan Singapore in Indonesia
primarily to limits China's influence
makes them see us as a rival and their
own sphere of influence fourth the two
countries competition for scarce energy
resources and investment opportunities
in markets such as Africa Central Asia
Southeast Asia which pitted India and
China as competitors with each other
usually the China's advantage and
finally China's reluctance to support
Indian and for that matter Japanese
aspirations to a permanent seat in the
UN Security Council because it has no
desire to dilute its own status as a p5
member by sharing it with another Asian
power so the usually complacent elephant
is wary of the hissing dragon and the
sino-indian frontier is unlikely to
remain quiet needling and anxious to
please New Delhi on its troubled
northern
orders helps China keep India guessing
about its intentions exposes the giant
democracy's vulnerabilities with
elections looming and cuts of potential
strategic rival to size I do fear there
might be more incidents on the border
and while we are focused on the threats
to our safety from Islamist terror it's
clear that India cannot afford to relax
our vigilance on our northern borders
now those are incomplete reflections
that leaves us just on to 20 minutes for
our exchanges but I don't want to leave
you on a pessimistic note though I've
laid out a lot of good and bad news no
serious decision-maker in either Beijing
or New Delhi wants the bad news to
prevail India has too much self-respect
to ever see itself as a counterweight to
China its bilateral relationship with
Beijing has its own logic independent of
any third countries the economic
cooperation I've described and the
potential for increasing trade between
the two countries could still prove more
significant than either old or new
tensions on the borders as long as we
don't see ourselves as rivals in a
zero-sum game and I don't think we do
yet in his recent book rivals bill
Emmitt quoted an unnamed senior Indian
official as saying both of us think that
the future belongs to us we can't both
be right actually I believe they can
both be right it's just that it'll be
two very different futures and they can
be room for both in the world of
tomorrow thank you very much
thank you very much indeed and for
particularly for taking us on a tour of
so many horizons that in one lecture why
don't you like to field your own
questions and yep
first of all I'm not entirely sure how
protectionist the Obama administration
is going to be there's some political
rhetoric about protectionism which is
understandable but they're yet to be
translated into concrete policies for
example when they speak of ending tax
breaks for countries that for companies
that outsource jobs what exactly does
that mean which taxes and and what tax
incentives will they give to keep jobs
in America rather than send them out and
will those incentives outstrip the
obvious financial advantages to the
bottom line of a company from
outsourcing jobs elsewhere these things
are frankly yet to be clarified and I
think it's premature for us to assume
that they will be very protectionist I
just don't see America doing without the
enormous number of goods number and
range of goods it imports from China
right now so you're not going to
overnight change things because if you
do consumers in an economic crunch are
suddenly going to find themselves paying
say four times the price for
american-made pair of running shoes than
they would for one made in China or
whatever and this is something that
politically would not make a lot of
sense so I'm not alarmist yet about
protectionism in this country whether
that will therefore have an impact in
China and India China and India already
improving their trade with or without a
change of American policy there was
initially a lot of hesitation from
Indian companies about the risks of
dumping by the Chinese manufacturers and
India did bring a couple of anti dumping
actions against China and it's true that
there's some businesses in which China
has essentially Chinese manufacturers
have essentially ended production
in India certain kinds of toys certainly
but even more sophisticated stuff I was
talking to somebody about certain colors
of colors of dyes chemical dyes certain
kinds of paints
oddly enough China has such economies of
scale on these things have simply
rendered the entire Indian manufacturing
these products unviable and that kind of
that kind of thing may create a certain
amount of anxiety in the indian space
unless china is equally open to import
in what india can offer which which
means to be seen i also think that both
countries can do much more to open up
the human traffic between them
particularly tourism right now we've got
the very controlled indian pilgrimage to
kailash a month or over but we don't
really have extensive amounts of free
issuance visas on both sides and i think
one day the chinese are now beginning to
discover the world and are free to
travel and have the resources could
discover India in a big wave and you got
people interested for example in in
previous sites of Chinese travel and
pilgrimage but also people interested
just in in seeing different parts of the
world and and we could open up there and
so on so those are all reasons why the
two countries could do more together but
I'm not necessarily sure that either
would see the other as a substitute for
what they might lose out from a
protectionist America yes
I know a lot less about the Chinese
Russian border but they haven't been
incidents there for a heck of a long
time they wanted two famous incidents
including one during the Cold War when
they seemed to be mobilizing on both
sides but they've not been very many
whereas in the Indian Chinese border
you're talking 170 incidents in 2007
more than 213 in 2008 that's pretty
serious stuff by comparison with one or
two or three and the Chinese on the
other side of Russian border so I don't
know and I think part of the problem is
that the the nature of the dispute is
more fundamental because China
essentially argues that the line itself
is a legitimate that it was drawn by
imperialists which is a little more
complicated in the case of Tsarist
imperialism than in the case of a
British imperialism so I think I think
that the the Indian border issue goes
fundamentally to - - to that question
and of course to China's great profound
almost irrational attachment to itself
and tea over Tibet which is the border
in question the border we're talking
about is almost entirely between Tibet
and India so that's the the big concern
they've got yes mam ban
or melting
it is a huge topic I mean the
environmental issues are serious in both
countries and that's why both countries
have changed their position on the
global warming debate considerably in
the last 15 years if you look at the
original Indian Chinese position it was
essentially one of denial right it was
the reason the planets and am assuming a
global warming is because you guys in
the industrialized world spent 200 years
making yourselves rich and polluting the
planet now we've discovered ways of
making ourselves rich and you've
discovered the environment tough you
know we're not going to do it now they
move from there quite a bit because
obviously Indians and Chinese are
themselves in a choking on a flu and Sun
on bad air and and suffering the
consequences and so they have now begun
to say yes we understand there is a
problem but you have to bear a larger
share of the cost because you're a
larger contributor to the problems give
us clean air technologies give us help
and and of course there is the the whole
per capita argument that India makes
even more strongly than China which is
that in absolute numbers India and China
right up there in the top 10 polluters
in the world but on a per capita basis
the u.s. is number 1 India somewhere
like one hundred and twentieth of 190
countries in the world so again one has
to look at allowances in countries where
there is a genuine problem of serious
poverty you can't say we will accept
environmental constraints that will
denies the possibility of pulling people
beyond the poverty line we've got to be
able to have industries that employ them
and so on so make it easier and more
feasible for us to develop industries
that use clean air technologies and and
and other technologies that help us to
be able to avoid damaging the
environment and contributing to
greenhouse gases and so on and do more
yourselves I mean this is the other
thing just today I was reading on the on
the internet about how the the amount of
greenhouse gases contributed by
Britain's failure to adequately heat to
insulate their own homes during winter
and the amount of heating they consume
vastly outstrips you know large portions
of what India and China are doing and
there lots of things that the developed
world could also do to set an example to
the rest that's on the sort of classical
sort of environmental debate thing
between the two countries directly there
is a serious issue you men
the glaciers but there's also the river
systems and there's some real worry
about China's plans to dam the
Brahmaputra which India has already
begun raising diplomatically so far it
hasn't become a big international
incident but there is no down river
treaty I'm in the ironically India and
Pakistan at the Indus Waters Treaty the
headwaters of all the rivers that flow
in Pakistan India and even during times
of war India has not interrupted their
flow in any shape or form here the time
of a good relationship relatively
speaking in a peaceful relationship
china is essentially threatening to
transform India's economic fortunes for
the worse by taking waters away the
Brahmaputra which they call the Tsangpo
I think sample and which flows down down
through the Tibetan Plateau and in
across Nepal into India that is a vital
source of nourishment and sustenance for
India so it's it's a potentially very
serious issue that we hope the two
countries will have the common sense to
effectively negotiate and resolve but it
could be a potential flashpoint for a
future version of the speech
oh I think it's the most seriously
dangerous place in the world right now
that is that particular combination of
circumstances Afghanistan as you said is
wobbling Pakistan sadly is also wobbling
and that what we've seen with the
troubles on the afghan-pakistan border
have spilled over both into large areas
of Pakistan and of course into
Afghanistan itself the real tragedy here
is that is that this problem is man-made
as it were and it was created first of
all in the creation training equipping
of the Mujahideen to overthrow the
Soviets in Afghanistan so a lot of this
I'm afraid some of these chickens are
coming home to roost these some of these
chickens are born out of American eggs
laid in the 1980s against the Soviets
but then the the triumph in 88 from the
withdrawal of the soviets inspired the
pakistani isi to turn their attentions
to elsewhere saying look if this can
work against the soviets we can make it
work against the Indians and they
decided to systematically use terrorism
as an instrument of their foreign policy
and their strategic defence policy and
the result has been that they like good
old dr. Frankenstein and the novel they
created a monster which is now escaped
their control and the monster that has
escaped their control is now threatening
Pakistan zone sputtering democracy as
well as risking engulfing the entire
region in its in its in its wake what
can we do certainly India is working
with a colossal amount of self-restraint
in response to the the Mumbai attacks
working diplomatically with America to
try and put pressure on Pakistan to to
react responsibly and not as Pakistan
initially did in a state of denial about
what happened in Mumbai and Pakistan's
own complicity in what has been
generated and America would have to
continue doing its damnedest to ensure
that those forces within the Pakistani
establishment that have at the very
least condoned if not orchestrated some
the recent actions are brought to heel
there is no question that the Taliban /
al-qaeda elements on the border with
them with Afghanistan the very ones of
attack need two NATO forces and so on
have had assistance from the Pakistani
military and Pakistani intelligence in
fact the bombing of the Indian Embassy
in Kabul the suicide bombing last July
was traced by American intelligence I'm
not quoting anything classified the
American intelligence agency spoke to
the New York Times you can google it
saying that this was done by the
Pakistani into services intelligence the
ISI and the intelligent intelligence
source went on to say what surprised him
was how little trouble the Pakistanis
had taken to cover their own
fingerprints It was as if he said he or
she were and who the source was said the
Pakistani were trying to send a signal
to the Indians look what we can do to
you in Afghanistan and of course a few
months later what was done in India so
it's a very very serious situation and
sadly it's it's it's it's fueled by the
extraordinary generosity of American
military aid ostensibly granted 11
billion dollars since 9/11 ostensibly
granted to fight terror some of which at
least if not much of it having gone into
the into into nourishing those who have
been fomenting encouraging guiding
commanding terror it's truly an alarming
frightening thing China's role so far
has been somewhat mixed there's no
question that China saw Pakistan is an
extremely useful agent in the region to
curb both Indian and in relation to
Afghanistan American strategic interests
keep them guessing keep them on
tenterhooks that sort of thing and as
recently as two years ago when America
tried to ban him out to Dawa the group
that is the lashkar-e-taiba reborn a
China blocked that ban in the Security
Council after the Mumbai attacks in
November however China changed its mind
and actually supported the attempt by
the US and Britain to get Jamaat to Dawa
proscribed why partially because I
believe China which has been coming of
age on the international stage and I've
been watching this at close quarters in
the Security Council there are my UN
days I think China now genuinely
believes that it's no longer compatible
with its increasing self-image as a
responsible player in the international
system to continue giving a shield to
people who are conducting terrorist
actions nonetheless China's strategic
interests are with Pakistan and not with
either India or the u.s. in that area
and so the danger is if Pakistan wants
to continue walking on the tightrope
will China instead of adding to the
diplomatic pressure on them help them
ease that pressure we don't know but
it's not impossible that they might do
it certainly bears watching they do
they've got the wiggers they've got
they've got significant issues because
some of these fellows appear to have
been inspired by and in some cases even
trained by elements in Pakistan but at
the same time they seem to be reasonably
satisfied at in that case this has not
been officially inspired I mean it's
very clear that no official instance of
the Pakistani state has any interest in
destabilizing western China
whereas elements attached to the
Pakistani state notably the military
have a very conscious interest in
destabilizing India and Afghanistan gosh
you should really be playing traffic cop
I like it
very well-informed ah final word is
about ten days away so this is a brief
foray into reflections on other subjects
but being in India for a few weeks early
this year I'm heading back there in
mid-march and almost certainly the
answer is yes I've been writing for
quite some time about how in India to
shame that now democracy the educated
middle class has an abdicated the
political space to other people we seem
to be divided amongst kids who are good
at taking exams and go into the IAS or
the ifs so become lawyers or doctors or
engineers and leave politics the kids
who aren't good at taking the exams
right so the result is we in many cases
not all many cases are led by people who
are not worthy of the society they're
trying to lead and I think it's time
that that others sorry they could make a
difference in the system we might all
fail first of all being defeated by the
electorate and if not perhaps being
defeated by the system ballots it's
worth trying and I think if the
opportunity is confirmed as I said it
should be within a week or 10 days I
will take the plunge one final question
at the back yeah
talk a little louder
thank you both for your question and for
the initial comment I'm very glad you
made that comment because it is rather
instructive that unlike Pakistan visibly
India where unfortunately the textbooks
in Pakistan are written to promote
hatred of India with historical myths
about a 5000 year war between Hindus and
Muslims and all sorts of nonsense in
China there's a kind of historical
amnesia about a conflict that's only
four decades old which is quite quite
good and I thought I welcome that I've
been to China many times and spoken it
on campuses and I'm always gratified
because the first time I went I wondered
whether I would be seen as some sort of
enemy and I wasn't on the contrary I
found a tremendously warm and welcoming
reaction from Chinese students and what
little they seemed to know about India
and they know very very little indeed
appears to be fairly benign and I
congratulate China on that I think as
long as there isn't that negativism
there is much more scope for better
people-to-people relations and you are
you're right to mention Buddhism as I
said tourism perhaps starting with the
pivot of of Buddhist centers in India
could be a good way to restore that
certainly I would recommend to you a
chapter in Amartya Sens book the
argumentative India about relation
between India and China and the ancient
days it's absolutely fascinating and
he's done some remarkable research and
some of it is a secondary search all
very well footnoted about these contacts
and there's one marvelous Marv the story
about a Chinese in the fourth or fifth
century I think who came to university
in India studied did so well that he was
offered a professor professorship stay
on and taught then finally said he had
to go back home and back to China and
taught in a university in China and then
some Indian faculty members came to
China and visited him and correspondence
has survived of that visit with and it
is it reads like something that could
have been written 1,500 years later
today you know this guy asking so how is
so-and-so did he get tenure
I'm not joking I mean it's the most
extraordinary thing and this sort of
extraordinary warmth and sort of shared
experience intellectual experience
cultural experience was a characteristic
of India and China for a very long time
which explains the romanticism of
Jawaharlal Nehru India's first prime
minister who had this whole notion in
during the nationalist period of India
and China as the two great Asian
civilizations that have been humbled by
by foreign invasion and right throughout
the 20s and 30s he wrote about China
initially the China of the Kuomintang in
Chiang kai-shek later the China Mao with
a great deal of admiration in fact he
insisted on inviting China to to his
Asian relations conference then when the
PRC was formed India was very quick to
recognize it even though many countries
did not do so
India sponsored China's entry into the
world of Indian to deploy our
international diplomacy it ferried
Chinese diplomats to talks on Indian and
Air India planes in fat one Air India
plane was blown up by suspected
Taiwanese saboteurs because it was
carrying the Chinese delegation to the
lowest talks I think it was bun dong
talks Nehru personally introduced Jo and
I to the other other leaders of what
became the afro-asian summit and there
are there after the the non-aligned
movement but I think China actually
resented this you know they they seem to
see India as the Chinese leadership as
developing pretensions above its station
who are the Indians to patronize us and
this raises fair nine-nine is a great
expert on all of this and he's sitting
right there and I think that may have
partly lane behind what happened in 62
because when the 62 war occurred Lee
Shao Qi said we're going to teach India
lesson and then 16 years later when
China attacked Vietnam dong Zi ping
actually said we're teaching Vietnam a
lesson the way we taught the Indians in
62 so that kind of thing doesn't
obviously is good on well in Delhi and
it doesn't go down very well but I still
feel that you may be right that the
hostility is confined
a small section of people who focus on
foreign policy issues frankly if you
read the academic journals that are
published in China I can only read them
in translation on the Indus indo-chinese
I mean the sino-indian border is
blood-curdling stuff I mean they've been
articles in the last three months that
of call for call for actual military
action you know to take back
quote-unquote the territories of
Arunachal Pradesh so there is the small
segment of Chinese academia how
influential there on the policy we don't
know some of them are writing for PLA
approved journals I mean we should worry
about them trying to use force I'm just
saying all of this does exist but you
made the very important point that I
wanted to underscore that amongst
ordinary Indians and Chinese there is no
such hostility on the population
question frankly there is not much
common ground a china tried a very
draconian one-child policy to some
degree it worked in keeping your
population growth down another degree it
hasn't worked because you've created
huge social problems on the one hand and
secondly you've created a situation that
is going to come to haunt you in recent
future decades when one child is going
to be supporting four grandparents so if
you have four grandparents to look after
young man because you seem to be of an
age to have been one child in your
family that is going to be a serious
challenge for young Chinese India had a
very brief experiment for 20 months with
a more draconian approach during mrs.
Gandhi state of emergency in 1977 in a
democracy you can't do that sort of
stuff it failed comprehensively and mrs.
Gandhi and her government were turfed
out of the next election and after that
no one has tried any compulsory means in
many ways India's understanding of the
issue is broadly correct which is a
development is the best contraceptive
that people aren't poor because they
have too many children they have too
many children because they're poor
because children become a source of
Social Security and investment in their
future children you don't know if the
children are going to survive because
your health care isn't good enough so
you have many children hoping some will
survive to look after you in your old
age you're not going to send them off to
be educated so they're not a net loss to
you instead you send them out to the
fields to work or send them out to
factories to weave carpets so so so
footballs or whatever but when you start
when
cumin takes place and more opportunities
come more children survive they're not
dying anymore
and you have to send them to school and
when you send them to school you've got
to get them uniforms as meals all sorts
of things children become an expense and
not immediately an asset you start
having fewer and all of this has been
demonstrated in the West it's been
demonstrated in Africa it's being
demonstrated in many parts of India with
development family size work shrink and
that may be the way to deal with
population I I just don't see India and
China reading off the same the same sort
of book as it were on the issue of
population policies the results will be
different and and perhaps in some ways
our experiences explain that difference
and our systems explain that difference
thank you very much I would love to have
carried on